you've done so much stunt work and so
much action
you know is there off top of your head a
sequence
one sequence or one stunt you were asked
to do that's like the most ridiculous or
the
one that really made you laugh yeah well
the thing is they don't ask you through
the stunts
i ask to do the stunts of course that's
the stupid thing i am
living walking barely walking testimony
to the fact that you should always say
no to the actors when they ask because
i'm carrying
so many lifelong injuries that i should
never
i should never have been allowed to do
the things that i did uh in this thing
this thing this this film um you know
i'm running away from lava and fireballs
and stuff no there might not be an
exploding volcano but there was a lot of
fire on the set
and a lot of smoke and ash and boulders
you know and not real boulders but you
know
stuff flying at you and a lot of very
hot things blowing up around me
and um i don't speak mandarin
so when they're all screaming watch out
on your left it's going on your eyes but
i don't know what they're talking about
so uh and also i quite liked the chaos
of
trusting that they weren't gonna blow me
up so dodging things when they appeared
um but for a lot of it as you'll know if
you've seen it i have a little
seven-year-old girl in my arms at the
end
and she had not volunteered to be
running through walls of flame
and dropped in piles of burning ash and
stuff so i felt very protective of her
but also wanted to get as close to the
flame as possible so that it looked real
and scary
and i got badly burnt and singed
everywhere in places i should never have
been
and um you know to peel the clothes off
me with a
spatula at the end of the day and apart
from which the smoke
in the air there's so much smoking these
little bits of
black paper in the air and white paper
in the air that would be emerging from
orifices
weeks after shooting and certainly all
the way through the night sneezing out
of my the nicest places that came out it
was my nose
um so uh you know is there a stunt
that's silly
they're all silly i shouldn't have been
allowed to do anything i've been hit by
a car i've been you know
the thing stunt men do things safely
actors not only do they not have the
physical skill often stuntmen
they don't do it safe we want to get a
bit closer to the exploding thing we
want to fall further down there we don't
we don't look like we're on a wire i
smashed my shins on a gideon raft series
i did
because the stunt man was very wisely
keeping his shins off a lot he was
jumping across underfoot he was on a
wire
it kept his feet up in the air who
looked like he had superpowers and when
he looks like his legs aren't i'm
thinking
gideon goes well that's that's what they
tell me safe i said i'll do it
he said you show him the stunt guy said
he can't do it he'll hurt his legs i
went
i won't hurt my legs but i'm not going
to do that i did it i nearly broke both
of my legs
obviously in fact there was a scene in
brotherhood i don't know how long you
got here but
there's a scene of brotherhood where i
meant to um two
groups of gangsters are playing softball
with each other because that happens
anyway and um i'm i'm meant to be you
know i hit the ball and i run to first
place and i'm gonna be tripped
and so i get up and i punch the guy
who's tripped me and i get hit in the
back with a bat and i punch him and then
there's a
melee and we end up on the floor when i
get there and as always i see someone
dressed exactly like me
you know the stunt double and they go
his you know his terry's just done
double i go
it's a trip i can do a trip it's not a
big deal the stunt guy goes you sure
it's
the ground's very hard and i go oh yeah
oh so it is it's like concrete the
ground i go
i'll be all right put a pad on or
something and the the dress that's great
because then we can shoot your face we
have to cut around here i go okay
good and so they all settle all up and i
walk through because you know i'm
filming you have to be hit
specific mark so so it's in focus it's
no good if you're out of focus
so they get on the marks they'll walk
through and they go okay we're about to
do the take at which point i'm going to
sprint
which i've never done before and the
director leans over and he goes you're
not going to do one of those stunt rolls
are you and i mean
what he goes we're not going to trip
like a stuntman and like roll and i went
yeah that's that's exactly what i was
thinking i do he goes
oh man don't you he's gonna look like
it's gonna look awkward
he went i went yeah because you've got
pads on there i've got elbow pads and
knee pads
but you know he goes yeah did just just
fall like someone's been tripped i went
uh-huh okay and the stunt guy goes you
call jason you're good with this you
feel safe and i went
and they go action and i sprint and
someone trips me and i go right up in
the air and i land
right on my head and my shoulder where i
don't have any pads and i can
feel this searing pain in my body i
stand up
i can't throw a left hook climbing
because my arm doesn't work i throw a
right hook instead the stunt guy's good
he takes it and
we do this big fight and melee and we
lie on the ground and they go
cut and i stand up and i go camera one
did you get it
he said yeah and i go camera two did you
get you're in focus your camera three
you're good because you and i went
somebody call an ambulance right now i
go straight to hospital
they didn't even use the take obviously
oh no
i could fill your entire memory card
with stories like that
i got one more if you've got time harry
potter harry potter
chamber of secrets i come out of
dumbledore's office at the end it's only
my second day's work i think
and uh and i you know dobby's i've given
dobby a sock and so he's a free elf and
and i take my one doubt and dobby blast
me across the thing
and it's it's what they call a pull you
know a wire and they pull you and they
land on a mattress i can't do that
they go no no we've got a stunt guys
fine i'll go i can do it i've done it
before in other films
we've got a big stunt team it's fine
we've got the wig we'll cut you know
all right so they do it with the stunt
guy and i only have to do the last
little bit when my head
hits the ground so you see my eyes open
stunned and they built rubber
flooring so that it's on rubber and i'm
only moving my head
this much but i'm embarrassed i didn't
get to do the stunt
so i put a bit too much effort in and
knock myself out
on a rubber floor yeah on a rubbish boom
head-butted the floor as hard as i could
slightly stunned for a minute
i feel like when when you're doing like
us when you're playing a character like
malfoy where you have like a very you
know
i'm assuming you did not you were
wearing a wig for the for that
yes i guess i was wearing a wig i
couldn't grow my hair down to my waist
every two years yes that's right
but you you have the wig you have like a
pretty elaborate costume is
you know it feels like it should be
easier to let the stunt guy take over
just because the look is
already so clear yeah yeah yeah oh it's
just fun look
i do this job i feel very terrible when
i speak to my relatives and friends and
certainly
during the last nine months when i you
know i've been lucky enough to work with
various charities i'm speaking to lots
of
people who are making a huge difference
out in the world working with
you know working in the health sector or
working with refugees or working
homeless people
i get to do this insanely childish
self-indulgent thing of
putting on costumes and makeup and
running around pretending to be other
people having vicarious emotions
it's it's absurd that i get to do this
child's play thing and get rewarded for
and get
social status i don't deserve from it at
all um
but i get to do this fun thing and one
of the fun things you can do at work is
jump around jump around the fire guns
and jump down holes and
you know fall into a river and all the
kind of fun things you know in a safe
environment
i've been to war lots of times with no
real bullets
you know it it is i hate the fact that
other people don't enjoy their job as
much and do much more worthwhile things
i'm ashamed of it but i get to do a very
fun thing and one of the funnest thing
is stunts